agency now is weighing whether to
recommend all Americans wear a face mask
that's been a big debate the last couple
of days watch this if you assume that
25% of asymptomatic the the only way you
would do it if you then sort of went
into areas that were high transmission
zones and had significantly individuals
then wearing masks assuming that they
were infected I can tell you that this
the data and this issue of whether it's
going to contribute is being
aggressively reviewed as we speak you
know Brent yesterday we heard from the
US Surgeon General's talking about this
and and he did make a point I thought it
was interesting if it makes you feel
better you know you can you can do what
you need to do but you might end up
touching your face more if you're
wearing a mask I mean we're all over the
place kind of in what we think we should
be doing but the messages have been
pretty constant coming out of the
officials on this instance yeah Harris I
think that this recommendation is coming
once there are enough and 95 masks in
circulation I think that all of these
companies are speeding up the production
I do think that they're going to make
this recommendation because of the fact
that you don't know if you have it if
you're asymptomatic you could still be
carrying the virus and you could be
transmitting it and so wearing a mask
maybe something that's people you start
seeing people do yeah it is to me a
conflict of messaging no to tell people
not to wear them is one thing based on
whether or not it would protect them but
to tell them not to wear them until we
catch up with in 95 mass where the
medical professionals have it and then
everybody wears them those are two
different messages which is why the
president said you have a scarf and and
until we get the mast if you feel
comfortable do that you know it's it
that's I think where they are